[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález ar de la
frontera entre belarús y polonia este
último país integrante de la unión
europea debido a la atención y al caos
que ha provocado la ola de emigrantes
que intentan entrar al bloque
comunitario a través de territorio
bielorruso la situación se convirtió en
un tira y afloje entre belarús y la
unión europea bruselas acusa al
presidente de belarús alexandre
lukachenko quien lleva 27 años en el
poder de fomentar la migración
clandestina hacia el territorio de la
web y también de usarlos como un arma
para desestabilizar la región y también
lo señala de tráfico de personas ante
estos señalamientos minsk ha criticado
la política exterior de la unión europea
esas son las dos caras de la moneda pero
en el medio están los migrantes que
están viviendo en medio de los bosques
del este de europa con el invierno a la
vuelta de la esquina y en medio de una
pandemia miremos en un mapa que les voy
a presentar a continuación algunos datos
importantes vean
muchos de estos emigrantes en su mayoría
son iraquíes iraníes y sirios aunque
también hay afganos y africanos ellos
parten desde sus países tanto por tierra
como en avión algunos que lo pueden
hacer hacia territorio turco
este tiene un punto de llegada y es la
ciudad de estambul la metrópolis turca
es un punto clave para definir qué ruta
van a tomar para llegar a la unión
europea a través de grecia a través de
los balcanes o a través de belarús
muchos vuelan hasta minsk la capital
bielorrusa
una vez allí los inmigrantes intentan
cruzar para entrar a polonia que es la
frontera más extensa que tiene este país
hacia europa también intentan cruzar a
lituania o a letonia estos tres países
hacen parte de la unión europea hacen
parte de la zona schengen y si bien
algunos pretenden quedarse en esos
países y comenzaron una nueva vida la
gran mayoría tiene como destino final
alemania en el centro de europa
la crisis migratoria ya ha sido
calificada por algunos sectores como un
nuevo frente de guerra desatado por
belarús con la ayuda de rusia que busca
responder a la presión de la unión
europea que ha ejercido sobre la ex
república soviética después de las
últimas elecciones presidenciales de
agosto del 2020 en las que lukashenko
fue reelecto para un controvertido sexto
mandato bajo serias acusaciones de
fraude lo que desencadenó las más
grandes manifestaciones ciudadanas que
hayan registrado en ese país para pedir
allí la renuncia del presidente ahora
ante este nuevo escenario de crisis
migratoria belarús
espera que le pongan algunas sanciones
procedentes de bruselas ya ha pasado
bruselas ya insistió en que va a poner
más sanciones veamos
entre minsk y bruselas se lanzan
amenazas cruzadas y las tensiones se
escalan hasta límites inexplorados el
ministro alemán en funciones aseguró que
los 27 del bloque europeo determinarán
nuevas sanciones contra belarús el
próximo lunes
22 que en el pasado dijimos que
demasiadas sanciones contra belarús
favorecerían que el país dependiera más
de rusia sin embargo hemos llegado un
punto donde las consecuencias deben ser
más claras por lo que considero que
áreas económicas de importancia como la
industria de la russa del potasio debe
ser sancionada una idea mayoritaria en
el seno de la unión europea
amenazas a las que alexander lukashenko
presidente de belarús no ha tardado en
responder apuntando contra la debilidad
de europa el gas
hemos aumentado los volúmenes de gas
natural bombeado a través de belarús el
oleoducto llamada europa está lleno
estamos calentando a europa y amenazan
con cerrar la frontera y si bloqueamos
el suministro de gas natural a jing la
crónica crisis entre minsk y bruselas se
agravó esta vez por la llegada de
inmigrantes a las puertas polacas de
europa la unión acusa a lukashenko de
promover la migración clandestina hacia
territorio comunitario como arma
desestabilizadora en contrapartida a mí
enseñada a la unión europea por no
asumir las consecuencias de su política
exterior y por incumplir tratados
internacionales como la convención de
ginebra tensiones diplomáticas que
mantienen a cientos de personas
bloqueadas en los bosques invernales del
este de europa un escenario que las
autoridades de naciones unidas- ya han
calificado de catástrofe humanitaria
hacemos un llamado a todos los estados
involucrados a prestar atención al
contexto humanitario de esta situación y
a resolverla de forma humana
según el medio polaco 'gazeta wyborcza'
al menos 10 personas han muerto en la
zona limítrofe desde el verano siete de
ellas en territorio de polonia
quedan muchas preguntas es
verdaderamente este un plan por parte de
belarús para usar la migración para
desestabilizar europa que puede hacer
entonces la unión europea qué papel
juega rusia cómo puede responder la
comunidad internacional y más importante
aún qué hacer con los miles de
inmigrantes que están varados allí en la
frontera en condiciones deplorables
expuestos al abuso de los oficiales
también a las violaciones de los
derechos humanos ya los traficantes para
analizar esta situación allí en el este
de europa estamos en contacto entonces
con yolanda becadas portavoz sobre temas
europeos en la amnistía internacional en
españa ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
madrid también en la ciudad de barcelona
se conecta a esta conversación nicolás
de pedro analista senior del institute
for
craft en la ciudad de londres y en el
estudio de france 24 nos acompaña aneta
del mar y conoma ella es historiadora
internacionalista también docente en la
universidad externado en la ciudad de
bogotá en colombia ustedes también los
televidentes pueden ser parte de este
debate dejen todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de nuestras redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram en twitter síganos como
france24 guión bajo esa santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo que
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios pues ya
tenemos el contexto tenemos el tema de
los invitados comienzo preguntándole a
yolanda vega en la ciudad de madrid
sobre la perspectiva que tiene de esta
situación como llamarlo es una crisis
migratoria es una crisis orquestada por
minsk y moscú o es una crisis de la cual
están tomando ventaja rusia y belarús
como lo ve usted
bueno más allá de poner etiquetas
realmente lo que tenemos aquí es una
crisis que está afectando a miles de
personas migrantes y solicitantes de
asilo muchas de ellas y que polonia y
lituania letonia
miembros de la unión europea están
adoptando una serie de medidas que están
en contra de las políticas que deberían
respetar obligadas por la unión europea
por la legislación internacional y la
legislación de la unión europea en
materia de asilo en cuanto a bien la
bielorrusia pues puede ser que esté
instrumentalizando está los migrantes a
estas personas que huyen de países donde
también están sufriendo violaciones de
derechos humanos
pero esto no puede servir de excusa para
que otros países de la unión europea
estén bueno pues pasando por encima de
la legislación de la unión europea y
declarando pues estados de emergencia o
bien
introduciendo algunas reformas en la
legislación que van en contra de la
unión europea con lo cual bueno pues en
medio están todos estos miles de
personas que ya están bueno pues hay
algunas que han muerto hay revistas que
están en el frío con lo cual bueno pues
están hay muchos menores hay muchas
mujeres muchos ancianos es decir son
estas personas las que están realmente
sufriendo nicolás de pedro en la ciudad
de barcelona su perspectiva sobre este
tema ya lo decía yo una crisis
migratoria es una crisis orquestada o
una crisis que está siendo aprovechada
por rusia y belarús cuál es su opinión
bueno es una crisis orquestada que
indudablemente tiene esa dimensión
humanitaria que estaba describiendo
yolanda pero yo creo que es un error
poner el foco en este momento en polonia
y lituania letonia y no en quienes están
orquestando instigando alimentando esta
crisis que son claramente belarús y
rusia que son quienes han
generarse esta situación de forma
artificial recordemos que esto se debe a
que vela de la luz ha estado
repartiendo visados en sobre todo sus
consulados en irak desde este verano y
no han facilitado todo tipo de vuelos
por diferentes rutas incluyendo vuelos
directos a minas y que el movimiento de
todos estos migrantes que llegan a minsk
está supervisado y controlado por la
policía y las fuerzas armadas
bielorrusas que empujan de hecho en
algunas ocasiones empujan a los
migrantes para que se lancen contra las
vallas y entren en conflicto con las
autoridades fronterizas polacas y no se
dirijan a los puestos fronterizos
por eso en tanto en cuanto no pongamos
el foco en los responsables de esta
crisis es decir en minsk
la crisis se seguirá grabando y hay que
tener muy en cuenta que ni minsk y moscú
tienen preocupaciones humanitarias y en
consecuencia cabe esperar un
agravamiento y un empeoramiento de las
condiciones y un aumento del flujo de
emigrantes a esta zona y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 en bogotá en
colombia neta su opinión sobre esta
crisis que se está presentando para
terminar esta primera ronda para el
punto de partir del debate es verdad es
una crisis muy compleja
orchestra tedio pienso lo mismo con la
participación de varios sectores y con
está una situación de vulnerabilidad de
la población que en este caso son en mil
emigrantes que han llegado hasta la
frontera pero no por su propia voluntad
moverse por todo este espacio si no hay
una ayuda no puedes cruzar todos estos
territorios a mí me parece que nunca
antes habíamos visto este parte de la
frontera de la unión europa ella tan
caliente polonia
pero es una frontera con una historia
tan peligrosa y
hacia un pasado donde sabemos que
polonia había desaparecido como estado
después alemania
unión soviética es una frontera que
duele mucho una frontera que evocan
nacionalismos y un pais belorrusia que
está muy como decir en una situación de
salirse y demostrar que las elecciones
en 2020 eran unas elecciones que se
deben a aceptar y en la práctica no
fueron aceptadas y hay métodos en cuales
fueron sancionados así que a veces dicen
es como un conflicto híbrido y yo veo
una complejidad grande para hacer el
análisis aneta hago sigo con usted
continuó con usted ya que en el estudio
haga la ronda a la inversa
y usted dice que puede ser un conflicto
orquestado desde minsk que estaría
entonces buscando o que está buscando
lukachenko en este escenario porque si
tanto esta crisis desde el año pasado lo
que tengo trate de demostrar que no se
pueden meter en los asuntos internos del
país que si hubo unas elecciones y que
se ha demostrado aquí en comillas que ha
logrado la victoria esto es lo más
importante pero recordemos las protestas
los jóvenes que estaban en la calle
protestando
entonces allí está el momento y cual una
dictadura y vamos a decir que es la
única dictadura en europa que trate de
buscar maneras como sobrevivir en una
situación cambiante y está en unos
factores unos factores y vemos el
problema del gas en este momento los
precios que están subiendo
aprovechándose y ahora todo lo que tiene
que ver con migración no es sólo esta
parte del mundo no hay rincón de este
planeta donde nos vemos
que se mueve por algunas regiones que
pueden ser muy fuertes o más débiles así
que es como un cóctel y yo no puede
decir molotov pero voy a decir un cóctel
muy peligroso que se juega de este mix
nicolás de pedro en la ciudad de
barcelona en españa le preguntó por la
posición que tiene belarús en este
momento que tanto se está jugando este
país usted también es de los que piensa
que esto es una crisis orquestada por el
gobierno de lukashenko hay en minsk que
tanto está poniendo en riesgo frente a
la unión europea a 27 países países
vecinos o belarús en cierta forma se
siente un poco digamos con la fuerza de
enfrentarse a bruselas porque tiene a
francia a perdón a rusia respaldándolo
si es muy dudoso que digamos
lukashenko se haya atrevido a elevar
tanto la tensión con las fronteras sin
contar como mínimo con el beneplácito de
rusia y no digamos con esta amenaza que
ha lanzado de cortar el gasoducto
yamal-europa porque se en ese tránsito
belarús esos es únicamente el país de
tránsito del gas ruso para los clientes
europeos y esto bueno puede inducirnos a
pensar que es parte de una estrategia
para seguir por parte de rusia para
seguir presionando para que la unión
europea finalmente dé luz verde al
gasoducto nord stream 2 que es una
tubería que conecta directamente el
territorio ruso con alemania y que está
terminada la infraestructura pero no
está todavía aprobado ha permitido su
uso porque no se ajusta a la legislación
europea y es realmente un proyecto que
va contra la lógica de la unión de la
energía de la unión europea y entonces
rusia está presionando belarús es una
herramienta para parar a esta presión
una vez que lukashenko además buena
medida garantizar su supervivencia o al
menos desde luego no está una posición
tan crítica como el verano pasado
2020 y lo que si las sanciones aprobadas
este último verano a resultas entre
otras del secuestro del avión de ryanair
en a finales de mayo en las de la unión
europea pero sobre todo las aprobadas en
agosto por eeuu el reino unido y canadá
están haciendo daño económico a al
régimen y bueno esto parece una especie
de chantaje no se ha dispuesto una
sanción es que me hacen daño bueno pues
yo mi herramienta para poner expresión
es en lanzar los miles de personas
contra las vallas y las fronteras de
polonia yolanda ya continuó con usted
quiero preguntarle a nicolás qué tan
asfixiado está el régimen de lukashenko
con estas sanciones que ya le han
impuesto a lo largo de los últimos meses
bueno el régimen es lo suficientemente
opaco como para que no estemos seguros
de ello
pero
económicamente es indudable que le está
haciendo daño aunque el aparato de
seguridad bueno a base de represión y
recordemos que en el último año y medio
lukashenko ha detenido a miles de
personas
ha habido torturas sistemáticas de malos
tratos en todo tipo de intimidaciones
etcétera y está empujado a quienes
estaban protestando a muchas personas a
huir de belarús no y cada vez digamos el
régimen adopta medidas más represivas y
restrictivas esto le ha permitido
sobrevivir pero al mismo tiempo
ha fortalecido se ha aumentado su
debilidad con respecto a su dependencia
con respecto a rusia y esto es digamos
esta es la parte del juego que estamos
viendo la reacción inmediata a la
diplomacia rusa pidiendo la unión
europea que le pague entre mil y seis
mil millones de euros al año lukashenko
como hace con turquía es claramente
buena parte del juego y también las
demostraciones de fuerza que está
haciendo allá moscú no sobre el espacio
el espacio de belarús y amenazan con
desplegar tropas tanto en belarús como
las fronteras con ucrania
yolanda dejo un poco el lado del matiz
político de este tema y paso a
preguntarle por un tema un poco más de
orden humanitario europa más allá de
esta atención que hay entre bruselas y
minsk se ha abierto otro frente de
crisis humanitaria ya europa hacía
frente a la llegada de miles de
migrantes a través de lampedusa de la
frontera entre turquía y grecia a través
del mediterráneo ahora se abre esta
frontera que como decía neta es una
frontera poco conocida en la unión
europea pero es una puerta de entrada
del este europa no ha podido sortear
bien los otros frentes en los que hace
digamos batalla contra esta crisis
migratoria ahora tiene un frente más
podrá euro para sostenerse podrá euro
para responder a esta crisis humanitaria
allí
bueno pues para ello tendría realmente
que plantear una política de migración y
de refugio que tuviese en el centro los
derechos humanos es decir lo que vimos
por ejemplo en grecia hace hace unos
años cuando la toda la crisis de
personas que venían de siria pues fue un
fracaso realmente de las políticas
migratorias de la unión europea y de
hecho hay todavía muchos miles de
personas que se encuentran atrapadas en
las islas griegas o en los centros de
intención que que se abrieron en grecia
y ahora en esta en esta nueva zona pues
lo que nosotros estamos pidiendo a los
países de la unión europea es por una
parte que no hagan devoluciones sumarias
porque son ilegales de según el derecho
internacional y según el derecho de la
unión europea pero además de eso que
demuestren de nuevo la solidaridad o que
demuestren una vez por una vez la
solidaridad entre todos los miembros de
la unión europea
y que el que entra en por polonia no
quiere decir que se tengan que quedar en
polonia o cuando llegaban las personas
sirias por grecia pues que se den tienen
que quedar allí sino que realmente haya
una política de reasentamientos además
yolanda
estamos hablando de polonia que es un
país que ha tenido también una tensa
relación con bruselas en los últimos
meses un gobierno sumamente nacionalista
que ha desconocido en algunos escenarios
algunas leyes del bloque de la unión
europea y ha puesto por encima las leyes
que se imponen desde allí desde varsovia
a que se estarán enfrentando entonces
los migrantes que están llegando a este
territorio con este tipo de gobierno
podrán ser expulsados simplemente
pasados transferidos a otro país como
por ejemplo alemania que si tiene un
poco más abierta las puertas pueden
estar allí en riesgo los derechos
humanos como lo ve usted
bueno en polonia hemos visto un
deterioro de la situación de derechos
humanos a lo largo de los últimos años y
efectivamente por ejemplo pues todo el
tema de la judicatura que esta falta de
independencia
de los jueces y demás pues ha llevado a
que la unión europea de una serie para
intentar limitar intentar poner coto no
a este tipo de deriva que no está en
línea con los valores de la unión
europea ahora mismo todas las personas
las personas refugiadas inmigrantes que
están intentando de entrar que no están
pudiendo pedir asilo porque no les dan
esa
posibilidad en polonia pues no sabemos
no sabemos si quieren quedarse aquí si
van a querer seguir hacia alemania
estamos viendo que en las últimas horas
días están está habiendo controles de
frontera entre alemania y polonia pero
todavía no tenemos muchos datos sobre
sobre esto que está suponiendo no
relación y acabo es también la comisión
europea quien tiene que tomar una serie
de medidas para qué
para bueno pues acotar y limitar
responder de alguna forma a esta deriva
que está tomando también polonia en este
tema en concreto
anita aquí en el estudio de france 24
aquí hay un guión particular que se está
repitiendo y es que siempre es un tercer
país el que está en la mitad pero aquí
los actores que vemos enfrentados son
nuevamente los mismos bruselas y moscú
prácticamente dependen viéndolo desde la
óptica que esto puede ser orquestado
respaldado y ayudado desde moscú vemos
el mismo guión otro frente ya lo vimos
en ucrania lo vimos en georgia
diferentes pretextos diferentes
situaciones pero otra vez en un
enfrentamiento unión europea-rusia
esquís y se inyectó de la parte que se
europa vamos a decir oriental o europa
frontera conducía sigue debajo de una
política donde rusia es la superpotencia
y está chocando con la unión europa ella
y aprovechen a estos lugares donde puede
jugar contra la unión europea ella y
jugarlo a través de terceros vamos a
decir que en el mar negro ahí también
hay tensiones vamos a mencionar la otan
esto es lo que más así como pone como
más fuerte en la región o la unidad es
unos de los países que entró primero en
la otan
1999 entonces están unas bases y está el
ejército y 10 el día nacional de polonia
que se después de la primera guerra
mundial apareció en el mapa otra vez
entonces se juega algo demostrando que
sin rusia no se puede decidir la
política en esta región y ahora desde
bruselas y yo no diría bruce trailers
angela merkel es la que más confianza le
da a la presidente putin para
conversaciones y ahora están los últimos
días de angela market y ya hubo dos
conversaciones esperemos que esto puede
ser significativo justamente la
canciller alemana ya saliente de su
cargo habló recientemente como ésta con
el presidente putin el presidente de
rusia y rusia no se había
pronunciado al respecto pero después de
esa conversación se mostró a favor de
dialogar de conversar es posible un
diálogo como lo dio usted después de
este empujón que pudo haber dado merkel
allí en esta en esta mesa el único país
y el único líder europeo que ha logrado
conversaciones con rusia es ángela
márquez en este sentido no sabemos qué
va a pasar después de que ella sale de
la escena yo creo que el juego virus ya
no es no pensar que puede suceder puede
ser y que está orquestado justamente por
estos últimos días de angela markel y
lograr algo sabemos que el gas que
reciba alemania es este gas que viene de
rusia claro nicolás en la ciudad de
barcelona hace algunos días hay como más
el ministro exteriores en funciones en
alemania dijo que ya le habían impuesto
sanciones a belarús i
que imponerle más sanciones lo que haría
es provocar que belarús dependiera más
de rusia qué tan peligroso es que minsk
y se vayan más hacia el lado de rusia
estamos hablando de la posibilidad de
instalar algunas bases militares o que
haya presencia militar rusa en belarús o
en el famoso corredor de su valqui que
es esa pequeña franja que une a belarús
con él con el enclave ruso de
kaliningrado que también es un punto
estratégico para los países que están
allí y sobre todo para rusia es muy
peligroso empujar a belarús hacia el
este
bueno
esto
evidentemente es una consecuencia
inevitable pero en tanto en cuanto no se
le ven los costes para rusia de este
tipo de agresiones lo que estamos viendo
es que la política de apaciguamiento y
de acomodamiento y de llamados
constantes al diálogo lo que vemos es un
incremento de un agravamiento de las
crisis en toda la periferia de la unión
europea y con rusia cada vez final
llevando a cabo acciones más agresivas
también dentro del territorio de la
unión europea incluyendo en algunos
ataques incluso voladura de depósitos de
armas en chequia o en bulgaria esa
situación es muy muy graves
lo que hay que hacer es elevar los
costes si en el caso de belarús poner
todo el énfasis en la en el apoyo a la
sociedad civil bielorrusa y a los
líderes políticos tan encarcelados en la
líder presidenta problemente electa en
en el exilio en svetlana ti ya no ves
acá ya porque se mencionaba antes la
situación de derechos humanos en polonia
vamos es incomparable
el deterioro la situación en un régimen
dictatorial como el de lukashenko en un
régimen autoritario como el de putin ahí
sí que hay unas violaciones muy serias
de las libertades más básicas y de todos
los derechos de los ciudadanos y de esta
población migrante que son tratados como
mercancías y convertidos en un arma y no
están protegidos por el derecho como si
sucede en territorio polaco donde hay
una democracia que funciona claro
yolanda en la ciudad de madrid llama
mucho la atención ya que estamos
hablando de derechos humanos garantías y
que estamos hablando de polonia llama
mucho la atención que el gobierno no
permita a los medios de comunicación
acercarse a esta frontera en donde están
sucediendo estos intentos de
entrar a estos migrantes procedentes de
belarús solamente se está entregando
información oficial que no puede ser
contrastada ni por medios
internacionales ni por los medios
independientes polacos teniendo en
cuenta que polonia es un país de la
unión europea ahí se están dando algunas
infracciones algunas faltas en cómo
tomar esta posición del gobierno de no
querer dejar que los medios estén allí
presentes mientras estas personas están
tratando de entrar al país
claro pues esto se deriva bueno pues de
haber impuesto este estado de emergencia
que no estaba justificado realmente y
que precisamente lo que pretendía era de
alguna forma silenciar ocultar qué es lo
que estaba pasando
en toda la frontera en toda esta
frontera entonces es muy preocupante que
no tengamos a una de las cuestiones más
delicadas es que ahora mismo no hay
información independiente de lo que está
pasando en toda esa frontera ni en la
penya en la parte polaca ni en la parte
bielorrusa porque claro evidentemente en
bielorrusia como bien decía nicolás pues
ha habido una represión absoluta de los
medios de comunicación de los venegas de
la sociedad civil en general con lo cual
tampoco van a estar presentes ahí en esa
zona de la frontera entonces hay un
silencio total y una de las demandas de
amnistía es que se pueda que queden
acceso a observadores independientes
internacionales de las sociedades
civiles de estos países
periodistas por supuesto es decir que
haya que sepamos qué está pasando con
estas personas amnistía internacional-
intentó llegar a un grupo de personas
afganas en agosto no se nos permitió y
desde entonces es que ha sido imposible
no conseguir
acceder a toda esta zona con lo cual
todas las informaciones pues son muy muy
limitadas y es muy diciente que esto
suceda sin embargo añade yolanda que el
primer ministro de polonia mateos miró
vi aquí aseguró que ese estado actual de
emergencia a nivel local no se
convertiría en un estado de guerra
general dando un poco de calma a esos
ánimos ya esa incertidumbre que genera
en la sociedad polaca y en europa en no
poder tener detalles claros de lo que
está sucediendo del lado polaco de la
frontera precisamente porque como ya lo
decíamos no hay acceso de la prensa ya
llegamos a la recta final del programa
se fue más rápido de lo que yo pensaba
en la neta quiero comenzar con las
conclusiones hasta dónde puede aguantar
esta tensión presente en el este de
europa entre estos dos países entre
bruselas y moscú que va a suceder no
tenemos bola de cristal siempre lo digo
pero que puede usted revisor a las
negociaciones no hay otra manera es
necesario y tú marín
y en este momento hay algo interesante
polonia exigía que se ponga un muro en
la frontera murmuró algo
fortificado y bien así como se ha hecho
en otras partes se negó la unión europa
ya a apoyarlo y el mismo tiempo polonia
trate de decir que su constitución no
acepta la las leyes y todos los tratados
de la unión europa es posible y que en
esta negociación algo pase y con la esta
posición tan fuerte de polonia respecto
a la unión europea pero vamos a decir la
población civil los polacos son gente
que apoya la unión europea y un día
están preocupados que son base en la
frontera se son gente que lo siente si
pasó a la ciudad de madrid yolanda sus
conclusiones de lo que puede ocurrir en
este en esta crisis en este conflicto
que se está viviendo allí en el este de
europa
bueno realmente más que una conclusión
sería casi un deseo y sobre todo la
petición de que no se juegue no se
instrumentalice de esta forma a todos
estos miles de personas de inmigrantes y
de personas que están queriendo
solicitar asilo entonces que se les dé
acceso que se respeten escrupulosamente
las leyes de asilo y de refugio tanto en
polonia como en bielorrusia y en
lituania letonia y que tenga se les
examine individualmente las
circunstancias de cada una de estas
personas porque así lo marca la
legislación y se les dé acceso a poder
pedir asilo
y para el cierre de terminamos con
nicolás de pedro en la ciudad de
barcelona nicolás sus conclusiones de lo
que puede llegar a suceder en este
escenario
por lo que puede llegar a suceder bueno
hemos dicho no tengo la bola de cristal
pero evidentemente
las cosas pueden complicarse todo muy
mucho en las próximas semanas yo creo
que lo fundamental es poner el foco en
quienes están instigando quienes han
creado esta crisis y quienes la están
alimentando es decir minsk y moscú
cuanto más foco cuanto más presión se
ponga sobre ellos cuanto más se lleven
los costes para ellos más cerca
estaremos de solucionar y de evitar que
esta crisis siga aumentando la forma de
negociar de moscú es
hacer demostraciones de fuerza militar y
esto
lo está haciendo no sólo en belarús sino
también en las últimas semanas en las
zonas fronterizas con ucrania
todo ello con vistas a presionar al
conjunto de la unión europea y eso yo
creo que es lo que hay que tener también
muy claro y es muy importante esto no es
un ataque contra el gobierno de turno de
polonia que nos puede despertar más
simpatía o más antipatía eso es
indiferente es un ataque contra un
estado miembro la unión europea un
aliado de la otan y cuyo objetivo de
este ataque instigado por belarús y
rusia utilizando como instrumento sin
ninguna consideración humanitaria o
moral a estas poblaciones que tienen
bueno que están tratando de huir de la
miseria o de las guerras se busca
debilitar a agrietar o agudizar las
divisiones dentro de la unión europea
que es el objetivo final de este ataque
bueno pues ahí lo tienen las opiniones
de nuestros invitados del programa de
hoy a yolanda nicolás janet aquí en el
estudio de france24 les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros haber
compartido con nosotros sus opiniones
para la audiencia de france 24 pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nuestra programación sigan con
france24
[Música]